some farmers in the USA the disruption
of normal trade with China has forced
many of them to go bankrupt Dean
Reynolds is in Princeton Illinois that's
about 90 miles west of Chicago with the
story of one farmer who says he wants
business not a bailout Dean good morning
to you good morning we spoke to a sixth
generation corn and soybean farmer who
told us that China used to be one of his
biggest buyers but because of trade
difficulties with America China is now
looking elsewhere for supplies to South
America or Africa leaving American goods
with no place to go we've been here this
particular farm for over a hundred years
Evan Hall teen says a trade war is the
last thing he and his fellow farmers
need yeah we've seen decreased profits
for the last six years and mother
nature's throwing us a pretty tough
spring so it's definitely not an easy
time to be a farmer he says the
president's offered to help the farmers
through these tough times is nice but
you don't want assistance right you want
markets don't you ideally we would love
to have markets right exports is what
we're good at and that's what we want
we'd love to see resolution to the trade
war because china plans to impose
retaliatory tariffs on American goods
including soybean related products while
teen will plant only corn this year what
would you tell the president if you were
standing right here I'd tell them that
you know we've supported him from the
get-go on trying to bring China to the
table and make them more accountable for
their practices but every day that this
ticks on farmers are the ones that are
taking it on the job how long is this
going to go on before you say hey this
is too much you're ruining us out here I
think to a point you could say we're
already there
you know we appreciate the support he's
given farmers farm bankruptcies are up
all over and you know we're just not in
an economy that can handle this stress
much longer
now the American Soybean Association
said yesterday that with low prices
unsold soybean stocks are expected to
double but Evan Hall teen remains
hopeful and still reliant on the
President to get the best deal he can
Nora terrific reporting there Dean thank
you so much